[Musique]
décidemment les adolescents commandes à
palio musique voici qu'il impose des
minijupes bien sur l'adolescence et de
tous les âges
mais jusqu'à quel âge précisément qui
est elle aux femmes don manuel devant on
ne fait pas froid
bien un peu plus de l'autre côté vient
de bouge plus bas comme si tu courrais
un peu les jambes en l'air
oui écarte bien les jambes
bien sûr rien pas trop en avant tu me
regardes bien jeune
[Musique]
offrant à la plage horrible horrible
quelle horreur
[Musique]
c'est beau non
un roman
bien voir que des jeunes je serai le
plus heureux du monde où la jeune value
non tous les goûts et les envies pour
les polémiques si c'est quand même bien
[Musique]
la boîte c'est la roja convient bien à
l'école mais pas normal
pourquoi pensez-vous des minijupes celui
portant cet actif et vol là je ne sais
pas
est ce que vous les voulez naissance non
pas du tout parce que tu es jeune épouse
avec moi non je n'ai pas froid est ce
que oui les gars talon est ce que les
filles du rouge elles n'ont pas du tout
aimé choisir les hommes de mécha les
jeunes les jeunes filles sont absolument
d'accord les vieilles femmes s'en sont
gentils ça les amuse mais la france par
contre les femmes de 40 à 50 ans on sent
très méchante grossière sont
certainement très jalouse mon principe
une femme de 40 ans peut pas se
permettre de porter des jupes aussi
qu'on sait pas que ça leur plaît c'est
que en principe ce n'est pas ça beaucoup
de femmes ont envie de racheter petite
fille malade malade ne voudrait demi
jupes ou alors qu'elles ont des juges
une très claire dans les contrats clairs
passerelle donc une chelsea par exemple
ce matin la porte
voilà ma la taille et le turc ou madame
aux ailes levier et oui moi il me plaît
voilà madame oui oui cet été
certainement sa frappe fut rare mais ça
ne tiendra pas longtemps certainement
pas non tout ça vraiment indécent comme
ça mais il trouve 5 décembre la porte
parce que ce que ça me plait monsieur ça
m'amuse comme ça pour vous pour me faire
remarquer pour mais autrement sinon oui
oh oui
croyez jusqu'en espagne
tous
vous croyez que c'est presque indécent
une gamine de 20 ans chez comprendre les
rabeats qui ne va pas dire que mon frère
[Musique]
oh
les
[Musique]
on a tout le monde
on a vraiment des chats
pourtant il
d'accord
non
on n'a vraiment plus rien à smet
[Musique]
e
hum hum
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh non c'est un second but
je pense que c'est vrai on notera pour
la maxima ne donnant pas qu'ils ne
croyaient pas vous faire le mur
ce qui compte à la fin
mais comme
elle est très bien née
à défaut - peut-être mais c'est même
suivant la mode de toute façon la
province surmonte un an d'après je crois
[Musique]
quelle est donc la vie des femmes en
provence mais au fond des campagnes on
n'ignore pas non plus que la mode est au
maxi jusqu alors c'est plus pratique et
puis c'est quand même n'importe qui
pourrait plus facilement portes qui
claquent site est lui déjà pour
travailler c'est pas c'est pas ça va pas
envoyer le long oui mais personnellement
je réagisse comme immolé m'enfin je
rallonge un petit peu europe comme
surtout pour livrer plus ce que les
cours qui reste car avant de refermer le
journal
nous allons vous présenter quelques
images de mode je sais que vous êtes
directement concernés les couturiers qui
sont toujours en avance d'une saison
vous le savez affiche depuis quelques
jours les grandes tendances de la mode
automne hiver cette année il y en a pour
tous les goûts certaines lignes sont
floues m'a-t-on dit d'hôtes sont plus
près du corps
je vous laisse apprécier reportage de
yoba grégoire les images porte la griffe
de jean-marie lequertier et gilbert
usant plus impérative dans le choix des
longueurs les couturiers nous font
passer par des hauts et des bas très bas
chez popy moreni court très court chez
dorothée bis
long chez angelo tarn a dit
et cours chez christian lacroix par
contre une tendance qui s'accentue plus
des pôles de débardeurs leurs manches
furent épouse le décolleté tout comme la
manche qui colle à la peau comme chez
par la nuit maintient également de la
taille haute et effet de corse léché
fopits moreni le tablier du soir chez
christian lacroix
les carreaux sont de retour du jour chez
dorothée bis
du soir chez par l'adie avec effet de
jupons tutu qui donne un petit air de
french cancan
mais carreaux de rigueur chez issey
miyake on joue beaucoup les
transparences minijupe en guipure chez
dorothée bis transparence et fluidité
on vole chez par la nuit ou alors créer
très coquine la transparence chez
dorothée bis les hivers tristan noir et
gris fini nous serons en couleurs
vitamines qui donne bonne mine orange
qui tranquille oui chez christian
lacroix est puni pour commencer la vie
celle de mariée j'entends il vaut mieux
l'avoir en rose
[Musique]